it's great to welcome to the program
today federico
olivo who is president and founder of
lks
foundation a federico it's so great to
speak to you today
hi david please to be here so let's just
start with
i guess the simplest question or the
first question which is what what is lks
foundation
and what is lks coin
okay we the story started in
2017 so more or less three years ago
um together with some trends we were
observing that there was
something missing on the social networks
um we understood that to incentivize
uh content producers and to attract more
of them
on the platforms a good idea would have
been to
um to try to remunerate them so
we were wondering how to do this and we
thought a good idea
was using a secure cryptocurrency with a
very low cost of transactions
so that um this could be
anchored to the most common gesture we
do on social networks when we do
when we see something that we like and
we approve i i'm talking about the like
um so in 2017
we found in an association that today is
lks foundation
and started to work on this topic uh
trying to get to
a new step creating something innovative
and really useful for everybody
because um let's say that one of the
obstacles
on the diffusion of blockchain and
cryptocurrencies
is that they give a very great potential
but they are not yet understood by the
majority of common people
so this is the first reason that led us
to think about
the need to create a center for the
promotion and the
technology of technological and social
innovation so elky's coin
is the tool that we created to help us
reach in this goal let's say
and this is a coin it seems that the
coin
can do more than than one thing it can
help
content creators protect digital rights
but it's also a way to monetize content
is that correct
okay this is um the first thing we are
we've been
thinking about and how we developed it
and then there are several other things
that we're planning to develop
also through the fundraising that we
have been activating on the
ado crowd portal so um this this
crowdfunding is going to terminate by
the end of june 2020
and through this we also want to create
a non-fungible token so an nft
uh which will allow the content creator
to claim the authorship
of uh of its content so at the beginning
this technology will be
active through the portal of our partner
cam tv that is the first one
that has been introducing lks coin for
all these transactions
and through a simplified interface that
will join
we'll we'll join the verified i'm sorry
my phone started to talk
okay we'll join the verified identity of
the user through
a kyc procedure and we'll connect this
with
the the the content creator
so we're talking about something that
really solves the problem of the
copyright of digital content that is
normally shared and dispersed in social
networks we think that um
educating social media users about their
rights and possibilities
lkscoin will become the tool that will
allow them to have or
give access to any type of digital
content on any platform that decides to
integrate it
moreover users will retain the
copyrights
of the content so lpscoin wants to shape
a future
in which no one has to think about the
terms of views when choosing a social
network
since all their contents will be
protected and compensated for their time
to spend
in creating that now the lks
coin itself this will be a
tradable token can it gain value over
time
how would it become more valuable
well david obviously we hope so
um but i want to specify that our
primary
objective is not merely speculative we
want to remain on the market
for a long time we want to become a
consolidated reality
a point of reference let's say so to
return to our question we think that the
main driver for the growth of value
of a project is people so i mean that
through our current and future
partners we will be able to greatly
expand
the user base of of this project of this
token and so that's to increase the
demand for ltes coin
um furthermore thanks to the nft project
that i was talking about before
um we will have um further tools
further further things that will push uh
the success
of this project but i want to underline
that we're not just talking about
a good idea uh there are several points
because of which
this is a little bit different from um
other projects um
that in the in the initial files phase
of an initial exchange offering
they present themselves just as a good
idea we have been reaching already
several
milestones several goals that we
consider to be very important
we've been signing a contract with the
first social that is scam tv
and lk escondi is used now for all their
transactions
uh we have been signing a contract with
h trade labs
for the exchange that is already
possible lk is coin
free at currencies um today the coin
is been it's been used for from more
than 360
000 people and exceeds 30 000
transactions per day
and we've been um we've been reaching
the goal of more than 900 masternodes
so today how he is going as the official
crypto of cam tv
it is interchangeable with fiat
currencies such as hero
and uh you can also use it in several
practical ways um
for instance through the cam card of our
partner cam tv
so that you can use this this card that
is uh in the in the
uh um in one of the
um main main uh
cards here quit and you can go and pay a
coffee with it if you want so you can
already
use it to to buy small things there is
one more thing
um in order to adapt it to to do the
different structures needs
we also have been developing the
ethereum version of this crypto
that's interesting so will that be more
of a
user adoption play that using an
ethereum version
will pull more people in or is the idea
that it's more of a
scalability because the ethereum network
maybe is scalable is it a technology
preference
let's say we would try to put together
the advantages of the two technologies
it's like when you're thinking think of
thinking like like like this
um in agriculture for instance when you
do a graph between two plants
why do you do that you do that because
you want to get the best of the
characteristics of both
so on one side we have the native fx11
blockchain
that is something solid thanks to the
masternodes it also
allows multi-level participation by
users who want to support the project
on the other side we have the ethereum
blockchain that offers
a great versatility and and allows us
the possibility for instance of creating
an nft
and the lks coin currently you're in the
funding stage you've raised over i
believe it's 400
000 euro during the token sale so when
the token sale ends
will the token be immediately tradable
on exchanges will it be eventually
tradable but not right away
it will be exchangeable first of all it
will be primarily
listed on the a do exchange where we are
currently running our initial exchange
offering
um and so it will be exchangeable with
the major cryptocurrencies of the mark
on the market but of course we have
already been talking with other exchange
platforms
let's say that we have a clear strategy
of development in mind
oh okay so do you want to say more about
that i mean is there a path
to would you like this to be primarily
held as a store of value do you like the
idea of the transactional nature of
rewarding content
creators is it all of the above
oh do you mean about the the different
um other exchange platforms on which we
are going to
yeah in other words do you see this
token primarily
as something that people will hold as a
store of value
or is something that will be exchanged
for transactions
or maybe both well
um in our project we are also thinking
about this token to be used in everyday
life
so um if we think that a first
goal that is already being
reached uh because it's already possible
to do this
is the possibility to remunerate content
creators on the social networks yes
a second goal is the one i was talking
before about the possibility
to protect the copyright that we
discovered it's also something very
useful to counter fake news
on on the media platforms but the third
step we want to get through is also to
have something that it is used in
everyday lives so in the future we
imagine people that thanks to this
tool that has very small transaction
costs
will get into a cafeteria and get a
coffee or go to the baker and get some
bread with a kegels coin
are there other markets where the lks
coin
could be applied that we haven't talked
about yet
let's say that the possibilities of
development
um have no limits the only limit
of uh is time and
so we just need time capabilities new
people to work on these
and this is also the reason because of
which we've been starting
the um the fundraising because we want
to
develop more and more this project in
terms of uh coronavirus
coronavirus i mean has affected every
market
worldwide uh in in ways that were
predictable
in ways that were not so predictable
what has lks foundation
done to counter all of the or some of
the negative impacts of the pandemic
yeah this this is something really big
that never happened in
in in my life i mean i'm an interpreter
since 20 years
and i work also in in more traditional
sectors
but i can assure that this affected
every kind of market
and and and everyone's life so i think
this has also been affecting
uh cryptocurrencies were and
probably because of the global
climate of uncertainty uh that that was
spread all over the world uh investors
were scared in
in every kind of market but um probably
due to
the young development stage of
cryptocurrencies
um we will see a quicker response in
this way
so um moreover in cryptocurrencies where
there is a great potential this
still have to to to be understood and
developed so
in a certain way we can say that carbon
19 has
also been pushing a little bit in this
direction because
this was a problem that upset all our
normal habits
and also made us jump
a little bit more into the future
because forced
us to use the net more to carry out
our work or our normal lives to get in
touch with people
isolation you couldn't see each other so
it pushed to use more than network and
in this from from this point of view
lk's coin
is an element of the network and in its
small way it
offers tools and opportunities to
that digital world in which willingly or
unwillingly
we're all migrating last thing i wanted
to ask about in terms of the roadmap
for lks foundation and lks coin
what what's happening in you know
whether it's three
six twelve months what are what is on
the table in the future
with different projects as i told you
before the first one
thing we want to do is the development
of the non-fungible token because from
our market research
we have seen that the need for the
copyright protection
and the necessity to have a tool that
helps
into managing fake news so to help all
bloggers journalists to have a more
secure font of their
their news are some needs that
are not covered today on the market but
beside this
we also do something that is not
technological we also want
to to do something on
on on the place where our our
side is uh is now so to to
have a social um a social impact
and uh for this we want to create a
center for
the promotion and development of these
technologies
we want to put together a brilliant
minds and
have such a place in which it is easier
to to to
to help in farther development of our
ideas
and to get new business models in line
with times
so this will will demand some funds but
we think it is possible to create
something really innovative
like especially in our region and in
italy is not present
nowadays people can find out more about
this at lks
chain dot io we've been speaking with
federico olivo who is
president and founder of lks foundation
federico such a pleasure speaking with
you i really appreciate your time
thank you david it was a pleasure for me